firefighters and army Personnel have
extinguished a fire in the Bangladeshi
Capital that ripped through one of its
biggest clothing markets more than 4 000
shops were destroyed Traders say they've
lost their livelihoods some firefighters
were injured it took six hours to bring
the blaze under control tambia Chowdhury
is that the bank bazaar market in Dhaka
absolute devastation as you can see a
three-story building with tin roofs all
under the ground just within a matter of
few hours everything lost there were
about four thousand garments and
clothing stores that was in this
building gone in six hours to the flame
you can hear the smell the stench all
over here those onlookers and crowd that
has been a major problem here the police
the military they've been trying to
disperse the crowd and onlook US fire
service at real difficulty getting in
here because of the huge number of
crowds that's been in the surrounding
area there's no water hydrogen here that
has been a challenging Factor the
military has been using helicopter to
water drop since morning the fire is
pretty much under control at least 4 000
shops estimated to be hadn't gone down
the ground millions of dollars of goods
glow we spoke to some of the owners of
the shop I had two shops and one has
burnt down it's all gone now with
nothing left I am simply left abandoned
on the street
many of these fires could have been
prevented if there was firefighting
equipment inside that shopping area
talking to some of the shop owners they
said they didn't have any fire
extinguisher or anything to prevent such
fire now though there is no hydrant
there is no other equipment to take care
when there is a fire started in any of
these cases much preventable situation
partly because of negligence from part
of the business owners and partly
because of the lack of resource and
enforcement from the government side
there were fire incidents on previous
occasions but still no one bothered to
take any precautions despite this there
was no firefighting equipment available
to deal with such occurrences
they're devastated this is the month of
Ramadan they're waiting for the biggest
sale of the year
and now they're gonna have nothing the
whole family
and the extended family they will have a
very very sad Eid for sure